okay hello and welcome to the end game
class
for tonight's uh once again it is a very
special
at-home edition of the end game class
straight from
my home to yours of course my name is
caleb denby
and i will be taking you through some
essential end games
for more beginner level players here
tonight uh and what do i mean by that
i'm not going to be going over the most
most
most basic end games like the one you
see here on the board
but i do want to start by talking about
what you should kind of be learning
first in chess
when you first start off learning chess
likely you start at the
opening position of the board you learn
how all the pieces move
and maybe you learn a couple opening
principles
i think the most important thing to
learn first is
how to checkmate right after you learn
the moves and pieces
learning about check learning how to
checkmate is really really
crucial so end games like the ones you
see on the board
are sort of the first thing i think you
need to learn
so i would recommend by first learning
how to checkmate with what we call two
major pieces
that is a two rooks or a queen and a
rook or two queens
this is sort of the easiest checkmate of
all time these pieces
guard so many squares that you can just
walk the queen king up the board
but i also think it's really important
to learn
the queen and king versus king checkmate
and
uh the let's say
straight rook and king versus king
checkmate learning how to checkmate with
just these pieces on the board
is sort of something that's going to be
a bit of a prerequisite
for this class so if you don't know how
to do those things just yet
feel free to watch the rest of this
lecture still but be sure that you learn
those things
because everything i talk about today is
going to sort of hinge
on these basic basic basic end games
so make sure you have a good
understanding of how to deliver
checkmate
with all of these things and then the
rest of this lecture is going to make a
lot more sense
so on the screen i have a quote by the
wonderful
jose raul capablanca the world champion
from cuba
way back in the day and he has a very
very famous quote
that says uh let me get the quote right
here
uh in order to improve your game you
must study the end game
before everything else and the reason
for
this quote and the reason this quote is
a good quote
is because once you understand how to
checkmate and how to get
to these positions where you know how to
checkmate then it becomes much much
easier
to end chess games so our goal tonight
is going to be finding ways to reach
this kind of position
where it's the easiest checkmate of all
time where everybody
should already know how to checkmate
with these pieces
our goal is going to be figuring out how
we actually get to this
from a chess end game and even earlier
on in the game how we arrive
at this position so that we can play a
full game of chess
and defeat our opponents once we get an
advantage
so up first i want to talk about
a pretty simple position here uh white
has a pawn
and a knight against black's lone king
so what is going to be the winning
technique
in this endgame well as i've said before
our goal is to get to one of those basic
basic basic positions
where we know how to checkmate so we
don't really know how to checkmate with
a knight and a pawn against a king
but we do know how to checkmate with a
king and a queen
against a king so of course the way to
win this
endgame is going to be to get this pawn
to the
end of the board and once we get there
we will promote
to a queen we know how to checkmate with
the king and queen
against a king and then we should be
able to win easily
this is how end games sort of build off
each other this is why
uh capoblanca's quote says you should
start at the end game
and work backwards from there so working
backwards we know how to win with a king
and a queen
so now we know how to win with a king
and a pawn we just have to get this pawn
to the end of the board and promote to a
queen and this is sort of
the most basic core concept at the root
of
most if not all chess and games
using a material advantage to promote a
pawn to get a queen
so that you can thereafter checkmate
so how do we actually promote this pawn
against this king
well it's important that we use
everything sort of in our toolbox here
we want to use both the king and the
knight together
to overpower this king to get this king
out of the way
so that we can promote our pawn so the
best way
that i've found to do this is to simply
go one step
at a time so right now this king is
standing
in the way of our pawn pushing forward
so the best thing to do
is to use our knight to control this
square to force the king away
we can actually do that immediately here
with the move knight f1
to e3 this knight attacks this king and
now the king is going to have to move
out of the way
either to one of these three squares
because the rest of these squares are
defended
so the king can step back to d6 and now
already we can push this pawn forward
but first i'd rather get the king up the
board making sure we have total control
over the square now black has to move
let's say he plays the move king e6
now we have the go-ahead to push this
pawn one step further
now we have the same issue here we can't
push our pawn forward
because this king is controlling the d6
square standing on the d6 square in fact
so we use our knight once again coming
into f5
to attack this king the king has to move
back
now king e5 stepping up the board making
sure we keep all of our pieces in the
action
let's say the king cannot step forward
so he steps back again
now we can push our pawn up the board
one more step
the king can come back to d7 and now we
have the same issue as before
uh we have this king sort of standing in
our way on the d7 square
and so we definitely need to control the
square in order to win the game
so we'll start bringing our knight
around now the king has to move
let's say he comes back to d8s and we
can use this opportunity
to step forward and gain control of the
d7 square
the king has to move again now that we
control the square we can push our pawn
forward
the king comes back to d8 and now our
knight is thankfully
already in position to guard this d8
square
and so after knight c6 check the king
comes to c7
and we're able to promote uh this pawn
on the d8
square to a king to a queen rather now
uh after king takes c6 or even king v7
we have once again that basic end game
that we know how to win so
this once again is the core idea at the
root of most end games it's
getting to a position that you
absolutely know how to win
uh by heart so as
subakura in the chat is saying there are
some pitfalls in this end game that you
absolutely don't want to run into
and that of course is the rule of
stalemate
so when you have a king and pawn against
a king there's a very very common
stalemate to look out for of course
stalemate being
when the king has no legal moves but the
king is not
under threat so checkmate is when the
king has no legal moves and the king is
attacked
stalemate when the king has no legal
moves but the king is not actually
attacked
not under threat so to move king d6 here
looks kind of natural
to take control over all the squares but
this would leave the king with no legal
moves
and now this would in fact be a draw by
the stalemate rule
that's why knight c6 check and making a
queen
is the way to go so once again let's
review this end game really quickly
uh the way we win this endgame is by
promoting this pawn getting it all the
way to the other side of the board
how do you do that well you take it one
step at a time controlling the square in
front of the pawn
one step at a time and advancing your
pieces together so knight e3 check
a great way to start the king steps back
we can bring our king
up making sure it helps control all
these squares
the king steps over we push forward now
our battle
for a new square has begun so we bring
our knight up to control this square
king steps back we step up king steps
back
we can occupy this new square that we
just won the battle for
king d7 now we need to control that
square
so we move our knights the king has to
move again
we can bring our king up to control the
d7 square the king moves
we won the fight for this square so we
push our pawn forward
now the fight for the last square we win
with knight c6
and make a queen and that's sort of the
end of the game
and what's the power of knowing
how to win a position like this well
now this same idea can be used to win
with a pawn over here
with a pawn over here the pawn over here
really anywhere on the board
and not just with a knight you can use
the same idea of
fighting the king square for square
until you promote a pawn
with any kind of extra piece so what
does that mean now
that means the number of positions we
know how to win
has kind of grown right we know how to
win with queen and the king against a
king
now we know how to win with a knight in
a pawn against a king
so that sort of barrier to win the game
has become
much much much lower which means any
position now
where you end up up at night and up a
pawn if you can get rid of the rest of
the pieces
you automatically know you're gonna be
able to win the game
so that's how you know end games work
backwards and allow you
to sort of uh solve chess
of course not really but whenever you
have an advantage
this lets you kind of have a little bit
of a road map
where you want to go to actually end the
game so
let's move on from here to a
slightly different position um
now here we have a pretty similar idea
uh the difference is for one i gave us a
bishop instead of a knight
and for two our opponent now does have
a pawn to challenge ours so
chat room i i think a lot of you are
probably a bit
higher level than the aim for this
lecture but of course how would you go
about
winning this position can be fun to talk
about anyways if you
even if you already know it manny says
the idea of zugsvang
which i'll get into in a moment
famous trebuchet position not quite the
famous trebuchet position
because of course we have an extra piece
ragnarok's is grabbing opposition
okay so
and outflanking so there's a lot of
technical terms
being thrown around in the chat the idea
at the core is of course to to win this
d5 pawn
this is sort of go being like going
without saying in the chat room
because we have a ton of really good
chess players in the chat room uh
the idea is to win the d5 pawn once you
win the d5 pawn
next thing you know we're in that type
of position that we already know how to
win
with an extra piece in an extra pawn
against a king and then we can use that
position
to get to queen and king against king
and then we can checkmate from there
because we know how to checkmate from
there
so from here how do you actually go
about winning this pawn
it seems a little bit difficult because
this bishop can't ever attack this pawn
this bishop's locked
on of course the dark squares and can't
ever attack this pawn on the light
squares
what does that mean that means we're
going to have to use our king
to attack this pawn however it seems
like even if our king manages to attack
this pawn
our enemies king is always going to be
able to defend the pawn
so how do we ever actually win well
that's where these technical terms that
are being thrown around
in the chat sort of come into play uh at
its core
the idea is going to be to drive the
enemy king
away from the defense of its own pawn if
you can force the enemy king
away from its own pawn then you're going
to be able to capture that pawn
with your king so of course the way to
start
is by getting your king into the game to
start fighting
for these squares and start fighting for
this pawn
another great thing about this position
sorry excuse me
is that the bishop is controlling the d4
pawn so we never really have to worry
about the opponent
taking this pawn because our bishop does
a great job of controlling it
so with that in mind how should we start
what do you guys think
well of course the king should step up
to a square like e2
it should come to e2 and it should try
to come up the board like this
and try to get at this pawn now our
opponent is
not a nice person so they're gonna try
to stop us for example with king e6
the king comes to f3 and the best move
here for black i think is to play the
move
king f5 and now we're kind of arriving
at
our first technical chess term of the
day here
after king f5 our opponent has taken
what's known as the opposition so
there's sort of a rule
with kings where when they stand
directly apart from each other
one square away like this this is called
the opposition kings are opposing each
other
and the opposition is a really strange
idea in chess because it's a point where
you would rather have it be your
opponent's move
it relies on the idea of zooxbox
the second technical chess term i'm
going to talk about here
so what does zoogsvang mean well it's a
german word that means
that every move that you have every
legal move that you can play
makes your position worse so in the case
of white
if he didn't have this bishop he would
be in zugsvang
because he would have to move his king
and right now
because of the opposition the kings
totally oppose each other
kind of building a wall that neither can
cross but the second that this king
moves
third technical chess term alert the
black king can out
flank the white king so from this square
we control these three squares
now we've moved away to e3 and we only
control these two
which means the black king can start to
make inroads it can start to advance
gaining space and get towards impact our
pawn
rather than us getting towards his pawn
so
with that in mind you want to find some
way to sort of
you know flip the script on your
opponent here you don't want your
your own king to move away you want to
force the opponent king
to move away so what do you guys think
the best move is here
the guys in the chat room are already
ahead of me if you're watching the video
though
feel free to pause and try to figure out
figure it out for yourself
the idea is to play the move bishop e3
here
now what's the point first and foremost
it's now
your opponent's turn which means he's
gonna have to be the one
to retreat and allow your king to step
forward
secondly why this square for the bishop
well it's nice to control the g5 square
so that the king can't step here
otherwise
uh for example if a worse move like
bishop f2 after king g5
the pawn actually helps the king sort of
build this wall
and we're still not making any inroads
with our own king
so bishop e3 to control all these
squares
now the black king simply has to retreat
there's no other legal move
of course once again this is zug's van
for black
as white has taken the opposition so
king e6
now we're happy to come king f4 but
after king f6
once again black has taken the
opposition it's white to move
if white has to move the king he's gonna
have to sort of
seed ground to his opponent his
opponent's gonna be gaining ground on
him
so what should we play here what do you
guys think
so of course the guys in the chat room
are still thinking about this one
because it's very very tough
the move is bishop f2
and really any bishop move would do the
trick here
what's the point well as we said when
it's the op when the opposition is on
the board
you want it to be your opponent's turn
so the idea of bishop f2
isn't that we're doing anything special
with this bishop the idea
is simply that we're making it our
opponent's turn so he's gonna have to
give ground
to us so now king e6 to try to take hold
of the pawn
and once again our opponent has given up
the key
g5 square by moving this king away so we
can now
outflank our opponent using these chess
terms
with king g5 gaining another
gr another rank up the board
slowly advancing this king forward
now if our opponent wants to stay
defending this pawn he's going to have
to go to d6
now we can bring our king in with king
f5 or king f6
the king is going to have to run away
again if it steps back here
it gave ground uh from the opposition
to e5 now after king c6
once again what's the key idea here for
white
the key idea is going to waste a tempo
with the bishop
bishop e3 or any bishop move and now
all of a sudden the king is out of
squares where it can legally defend the
pawn
king d7 king takes d5 and we've seen
this kind of end game before
we know how to win it at least with a
knight with a bishop it's going to be
largely the same
we step forward with our king and push
this pawn up
one square at a time
now what's the last square we need to
control the last score we need to
control is d8
you can do it in this case with the king
or with the bishop
and make a queen and now you should know
how to win from here
so uh let's review so
now we are sort of expanding our uh
toolbox a little bit more here
we know how to win with an extra piece
and an extra pawn
against a king now hopefully we should
know how to win in most positions with
just an extra piece against a king
what does this mean this means if you
win just one single little piece
in the middle of the game or the opening
of the game if you get this sort of
advantage
and you get to the end game now you
should be able to win those games
consistently
and that's really one of the fastest
ways to improve at chess
is making sure you are winning the
easily won positions
it's the i think the fastest way to
improve at the beginner level
so moving on from here
let's take a look at a position
like this so it's going to be pretty
similar here
but the idea i wanted to point out is
now it's
it's actually going to be a little bit
more difficult in a position like this
to drive the king totally away from the
pawn uh it can be done here but i wanted
to highlight
that there is another way to sort of win
a pawn
against a king even if you can't drive
the king totally away
and so what am i talking about with that
well of course
i'm talking about the fact that you can
just overpower a pawn directly
even if the pawn is defended by the
enemy king
if you're attacking it with two of your
pieces then the enemy king
is going to be helpless no matter what
so in the first end game we looked at
there
or rather the last end game we just
looked at we won the pawn by driving the
king
totally away from the pawn and capturing
it with our king
now in this case we're gonna try to
overpower this pawn directly
so of course the start of it is going to
be much the same
we want to advance our king up the board
so king f3
king f7 king f4 king f6 makes sense
taking the opposition so now we want it
to be our opponent's turn so let's bring
our knight in
the king has to move uh in this case it
wouldn't make the most sense
for black to start pushing this pawn
because the further up the board this
pawn is
the more quickly it's going to get
overpowered for example here
king h6 is still defending this pawn but
we have
two attackers so we are in the clear to
just capture this guy directly
uh now so king g6 instead
and we want to bring our knight even
further in with knight f5
king f6 now those confident players in
the chat might just want to take
this guy directly and the reason for
that is they know how to win with a king
and pawn
against a king but if you don't know how
to do that you can still win this
position another way
with something like king to g4
and now let's say if a move like g6
happens we'll retreat our knight
attacking this guy the king moves king
g5
bringing the king up king f7 and once
again
it's that classic scenario where we are
overpowering a pawn
with two of our pieces so it doesn't
even matter
that the enemy king defends the pawn
because we have two attackers
allowing us to take this pawn with our
knights
and win this end game like we already
know
how to do now if our opponent tried to
do something like king g6 leaving this
pawn all the way back here
it's going to turn out the same we can
give this check
king h6 step up with king f5
if king h5 we can move our knights
and eventually king has to step back
king g5 king g8 king g6 now
king f8 and once again we can overpower
this piece with
uh our two pieces together uh
once again reaching a totally winning
position that we now know how to win
uh okay with all that in mind let's take
a look
at a slightly more realistic end game
here
and this is where i want to introduce uh
yet another idea
so usually in end games that you reach
it's not going to be just one pawn
against no pawn
or one pawn against one pawn with an
extra piece on the board
a lot of the time there are sort of
pawns scattered throughout the board
as is the case here the good news for us
is a lot of the time these are actually
easier to win
when you are the side with the extra
piece
in this case i want you guys at home to
try and see
if you can figure out the easiest way to
win this position
of course there are many many many ways
to win this position but i want you guys
to try and think about the
easiest way to uh to win here
what do you guys think the easiest way
to win
all right the chat room is discussing
their own stuff
which fair enough the chat room as i
said is full of pretty strong chess
players
because most of my lectures are aimed at
a higher level than this
but yeah now we do have some answers the
idea of course
is to capture this a pawn why is this
the idea
well because what are we looking for
we're looking for the easiest way to
promote a pawn
over here the king is defending all of
the pawns that are in our way
over here this pawn has no defense as
the king is too far away to help it out
so what's the easiest way to win we want
to attack this pawn
how can we attack this pawn well we can
bring on
uh bring on our knight to just come
and eat this guy so the best move i
think is either 95 or really any knight
move that gets us closer
now king f6 knight c4 king e6
knight takes a5 and we all we are
already
uh winning this a pawn and looking
to promote what's called our past pawn a
past pawn of course
is a pawn with nothing in front of it to
uh to stop it
well specifically no enemy pawns in
front of it to uh to stop it
now after king d6 i want to introduce
another really cool idea for you guys
in end games like these so
with the extra piece in this case a
knight and an extra pawn
uh it might seem difficult to keep
both of these pieces safe against the
flexibility of an enemy king right he's
coming in really really quickly
to try and take these guys but the great
news is
these pieces can actually defend each
other interestingly enough
you know with the bishop it would be a
lot easier because we just move the
bishop back and move this pawn up
and they defend each other but a knight
in a past pawn can actually defend each
other as well
how is that so well let's take a look
here let's say
knight p3 this king comes over to c6
a5 happens king b5 king f2
and guess what if king b4
trying to capture this knights this is
actually
sort of a lost cause because of the way
that kings are short range pieces
so the second that the king steps behind
the pawn
the king can the pawn can step up and
promotion
is unstoppable that's what i mean by
these pieces defending each other
the knight defends the pawn directly but
the pawn
prevents the king from attacking the
knight by
the threats of it promoting up the board
so
after we can achieve this sort of
position with our knight and pawn
the the rest is sort of easy we just
bring our king over
and win the game
now there is one more part of this that
i sort of want to talk about
and that is the fact or that is the idea
of the easiest way to now win this
position
so what have we done we've won the a
pawn for free we've given ourselves a
past pawn
on the a file but how do we actually go
about winning the game
do we bring our king over to the queen
side and try to promote this guy
or do we do something else what do you
guys think
what should we do to win this position
so yeah the chat has the right idea here
it's actually going to be a little bit
tough
to bring our king over to the queen's
side and try to promote
because our opponent is actually going
to start pushing his own pawns over here
if we put both of our pieces
on the queen side so in this case the
easiest way to win
is not necessarily to bring your king
over here but
instead to bring your king up here we
want to get rid of these enemy pawns
now that this king is no longer over
here to keep them nice and safe
so what is the job of this knight in
this pawn well in this case it's not
necessarily
that we're gonna try and promote this
pawn directly but these guys are acting
as great
decoys to keep the black king out of the
way
and once the black king is out of the
way it's sort of open season
on these pawns we just bring our king in
and we'll be able to
uh to take these guys off the board
so in this case this king has to stay
sort of tethered to this pawn
to king a6 and now our king steps up the
board
even if it tries to stop us we can get
around these pawns
and at the end of the day
we're gonna be able to take these guys
all the pawns fall off the board and now
of course it's going to be really really
easy when
we can promote one of these pawns uh
while the king is busy
over here so once again the idea here
is not to win the a pawn to promote our
a
pawn the idea is to win the a pawn so
that we
threaten to promote the a pawn and
distract this king forever
now with an extra piece this idea makes
uh is is really really easy
because these pieces can defend each
other as we've seen
this pawn and knight defend each other
but the same idea actually holds true
without the extra piece so let's take a
look
at this position here where we actually
have
even material but white has what's known
as the outside past pawn
the same idea as the previous position
so
in this case while material is even
we have a past pawn over here and black
has a past pawn over here
so how does this make any sense how does
each side having a past pawn
allow white to be winning in this case
the black king and the black pawn
are actually both further advanced as
well
so of course the idea here is that our
pawn
is further away from the other pawns
that's what makes it the outside past
pawn it's
outside everything it's way far away
so both of these pawns for each side
that is the b3 pawn in the e5 pawn
are gonna act as a decoy for the other
king
the advantage that white has is that our
decoy
is farther away from the action so after
a move like king e3
our king is being decoyed to this e5
pawn
however the black king is gonna have to
go even further away
and with the king further away our king
can grab this pawn and sneak over to the
king's side
much faster than our opponent can handle
so for example
if our opponent tries to be stubborn and
keeps this pawn together let's say with
e4
now how do we win this position well we
can just push
our b pawn forward until our opponent
is compelled to stop it right we used
this pawn
as a decoy we were never really
intending to promote this pawn
we were just using it to force our enemy
king
away from the action now we can take on
e4
take some v6 and next thing you know
we are eating all of the enemy pawns
uh now in this specific case uh white
has two pawns and so it's a pretty easy
win
but in a lot of these situations you're
gonna have to know
how to win with with just a king and a
pawn
against a king and that's something we
haven't talked about yet so that is the
next
essential end game that i wanted to talk
about so once again
the idea here is the outside past pawn
uh in this case it's a little bit more
complicated because black has a pawn as
well
but this idea holds true even if this
pawn
were not on the board the same idea
would be the way to win here
use this pawn as a decoy and then go and
take the other pawns
so let's look at king and pawn versus
king so the idea
here is going to be once again
that we need to promote our pawn it's
the only way we're going to win this
game
is if we promote our pawn and then once
again once we promote we should know how
to deliver checkmate already with a
queen
and a king
so how can you win this position how you
how can you promote the pawn
well let's take a look at what happens
if we play sort of naively
if we follow the same method we were
just following where we go
uh one square at a time all right so e4
now we have to take the e5 square which
we can very much do
the king steps away we step forward bam
we won the e5 square
now if the king steps over here we can
push our pawn forward
and after we move bam we won
the e6 square and we can follow the same
line check the king steps back we step
over controlling all these squares
keeping our pawn defended
and the king has to step back now we can
step up
and bam we control the e7 square
the issue that you run into is the same
issue i mentioned earlier in the lecture
which is stalemate if the enemy king
is successfully in front of the pawn as
he is here
you are going to draw
the game by stalemate the reason for
that is you have no way
of actually controlling this final
square on the board
without stepping to e6 first
now in all the previous positions where
we stepped behind our pawn
the enemy king had to step back away
from our pawn
in this case he ran out of board to run
to run to which means that this is going
to be
stalemate with the king having no legal
moves and the game
would be a draw so
the point of that is to show that if the
enemy king is in front of our pawn and
our king is behind our pawn
it's always going to be a draw however
there is a way to win this position
and the way you win this position is
with the idea
of the op opposition the opposition like
we talked about before that technical
chess term
where the kings stand opposing each
other and whoever's turn it is
is actually at the disadvantage so you
want to take the opposition
force the king away and then use
outflanking
also known as shouldering to advance
your king forward
so in this case there are two really
important candidate moves to consider
uh to review if our king is behind our
pawn
the game is always going to be a draw if
our king is in front of our pawn then we
have some chances
right because we control this e8 square
before the enemy king does
so the two moves that you can consider
here are king e4
stepping in front of the pawn or king d4
also stepping in front of the pawn but
in a slightly different way
so i think the people in the chat room
the good people of the chat room already
have some ideas here
and they are agreeing that the
move in this case is going to be not
king e4
but rather king d4 and of course the
point is
this opposition idea that i just
mentioned
you play king d4 taking the opposition
the black king has to move let's say to
e6
and now only now we play the move king
e4
once again taking the opposition and
it's going to be
our opponent that has to give ground uh
whereas if we played king e4 immediately
our opponent would play king e6
and surprise surprise we've arrived at
the same position
but it's the wrong side's turn now that
it's white to move
we have to move our king and we are the
one that gives ground
so by playing king d4 for example in
this case
black isn't actually interested in
advancing but he can
keep the balance and uh maintain his
big wall here the opposition against our
king
making sure we can't advance eventually
white would get frustrated
and push the e pawn and once again with
our king behind the pawn
it's always going to be a draw due to
this stalemating idea
so king d4 first king e6
now king e4 and it is white with the
opposition
so if the black king steps away what do
you do
well you look at the squares that he
gave up in this case
he gave up this f5 square and so we
shoulder the king or outflank the king
by taking the square for ourselves
uh now the black king should try to stay
in front of the pawn to keep it from
promoting
what do we do of course we don't play
the move e4 giving our opponent
the opposition instead we take the
opposition again
and after the king moves we look at what
square he gave up
in this case the the d6 square and we
put our king there
ourselves and now if the black king
starts coming after our pawn
we advance our pawn forward to defend it
and after the king steps back to e8s
what do we do
we don't push the pawn forward which
would be a
draw but we step in front of the pawn
taking the opposition
as we've seen the king steps out of the
way we take
the square that it gives up and now
what's the difference
well we won the battle for the e8 square
and we
are clear to push our pawn forward and
make a queen
uh okay so that was a lot to take in
that was a lot to take in right this is
probably the most complex end game that
i'm gonna talk about tonight
uh but it's one of the most important to
know
because once you feel confident in your
ability to win
these end games you're going to win a
lot of games
by trading down into this particular
position
right or a position exactly like this
where you have one pawn left
against the bear kings so once again the
key idea at play here
is taking the opposition from the enemy
king
forcing the enemy king to go back and
staying
in front of our pawn okay
so let's move along
uh here we have what's next
what's next uh another idea
of the outside past pawn i just wanted
to show briefly
is in a position like this a little bit
different than the first
one we looked at once again it is going
to be an easy win
for whites simply by advancing this pawn
forward
and then coming up and being faster
to take all of the pawns
and now either saving this pawn or just
capturing here
is going to be good enough right this
pawn
is free and clear just wanted to show
that one briefly
all right now let's take a look at this
position
so we've looked at the idea of the
outside past pawn
and here the idea is going to be
very very similar right we have the
outside passed pawn it's the same
position that i just showed briefly
but the difference here is that there
are bishops on the board
so how does this change things how does
having bishops on the board
make things slightly more complicated
well
let's take a look in fact the same
idea is going to apply here we want to
use this pawn as a decoy
to draw the enemy pieces away from the
king's side
and then we want to come in and win the
king aside pawns with our remaining
pieces
so how is that going to look well first
and foremost we bring our king into play
king c4 for example our enemy king is
going to try to stop
our pawn and now we can push this guy
forward
with b4 and b5 and then what's happened
now
well our opponent has done very well to
win the fight
for the b6 square so it's going to be
very very difficult
to actually gain control of the ds of
the b6 square
so let's say we play king d5 instead
we've sort of decoyed our opponent
pieces
to the queen side and now we can start
trying to come in
to take all the king side pawns right
this is sort of the classical plan that
we've seen
before you
uh use the extra pawn the outside past
pawn
to draw the enemy pieces away and then
you win the king side pawns so what's
the issue here
well the issue is if our opponent plays
the move bishop
to c7 believe it or not it's actually
going to be very difficult
to break through with our king after the
move bishop
c7 uh
so let's think about it here how can we
possibly break through
and win on the king's side after the
move
bishop c7 what do you guys think
how can you win this position uh using
this extra pawn
all right the chat room is not sure yet
and alex tell has the perfect general
idea
and there are some specific moves being
suggested in the chat here as well
of course really any move in this
position is going to
keep the winning position but the key
idea is that we can sort of hold
something over our opponent's head
what can we hold over our opponent's
head well we know
that this end game with the bishops off
the board is a win for white we just
looked at it it's really easy to win
use the outside past pawn draws the king
away and the coast is clear
to advance with our king so we've
already drawn
the king away so what we can do now
is we can say if the bishops come off
the board i know i'm winning
so we can threaten to take the bishops
off the board and
use this idea to get our king into the
game
so the move that i like the best here is
actually the move
b6 and this is a pretty
counter-intuitive move
at first glance you are just in fact
losing this pawn
directly if black wants to take it but
of course
black cannot take it because if black
takes it
you can trade bishops next thing you
know your opponent's king has been drawn
too far away
and the coast is clear for the white
king to come in and capture all of these
pawns
for example no
stopping the white king here from taking
these guys
there's just no stopping it
and an easy win for white so what's the
point of b6 well the point is we drive
this bishop away
now how do we still break through what's
the
part two of the idea here well we can
simply play the move
g3 and bishop f4
we can challenge this diagonal from the
enemy bishop
because we know that if black trades the
bishops
white is easily winning and this idea
holds true here as well
uh if you didn't want to kind of ruin
your pawns you can do the same idea
with the bishop on let's say on e5 here
just for example
g6 bishop e5 it's the same exact idea
the bishops come off the board and the
white king comes through
and wins the pawns and if
uh you know black tries to save these
bishops you really can't
uh first and foremost because these guys
would fall but secondly
if white wants to keep this pawn which
would make sense we can just play g3
kick this bishop away and now once again
we are invading
if our opponent tried to check us we are
more than happy to block
because once again we know the king and
pawn end game is winning
so once again we see this kind of build
up of the end games we know how to win
with king and queen against king
so that's sort of the basic part then we
know how to win
with king and pawn against king and now
we know how to win
with these bishops on the board because
we can transpose
into those end games that we already
know layer after layer
uh so this is like i said just going to
be an easy win
for uh white let's say it takes takes
and once again it's the same deal where
we come after these pawns
on the king's side and black is sort of
helpless to stop us
we once again are just going forward to
promote our pawns
uh okay we've got some time left let's
move on to the next one
now i wanted to sort of switch gears
entirely
and talk about another type of end game
another one which i think is essential
so we know how to win most positions uh
where we are up
sort of a clean pawn and a uh
and even if the pieces are even right we
get this past pawn and we use it to
decoy our opponents pieces away to
distract them away
and then we invade on the other side of
the board to win the remainder of the
pawns
these are really really common end games
now
another common imbalance is what if you
win
two pawns and have rooks on the board
rook end games are super super common uh
they're
probably the most common uh basic piece
end game that you run into
and so i wanted to talk at least about
uh what i think is one of the easiest
rook end games to win now rook and one
pawn
against a rook is a rather difficult end
game to learn as a beginner
and i don't want to try to to teach that
to you guys
tonight but i do think it's worthwhile
to at least know how to win
when you have two connected pawns like
this together
and so what is the idea here why is
you know this generally more difficult
than the end games where we're you know
just
up one pawn with minor pieces on the
board
well the issue is the rooks are very
powerful pieces
and a lot of the defensive ideas for
black
revolve around using this rook to create
problems
for the white king if the white king
doesn't have a lot of shelter
it's going to get checked by this rook
over and over and over again
and it's going to have problems sort of
running away
so what is the key to this endgame
here well the key is to understand
that your goal is to prevent checks from
the enemy rook
while pushing your pawns forward so what
does that mean
that means we're going to hope to use
our own pawns as
shelter from enemy checks and we're
going to use our rook
to sort of clear the path for our king
and our pawns
by getting rid of the enemy king the
enemy king
gets in the way so what's a good start
to this
well i like the move g4 to start with
advancing forward of course we want to
push our pawns forward
to promote them now rook c2 check would
be pretty sensible
let's say king g3 and just for example
to move rook a2
now what do you guys think the most
natural move
is going to be here
what's the most natural move so ragnarok
is already saying
the move that i do think is the best and
that move
is rook over to b1 and this might not be
uh what occurs to you at first glance
here
it makes sense to sort of have our work
behind the pawns to support them right
we want to push these pawns forward
the rook behind the pawn supports the
pawns but in this case our rook is much
better served on the side of the board
uh and the reason for that is that we're
going to use
this rook to control the squares in
front of the pawns
from the side like this we want to get
rid of the enemy king
so that we can push the pawns forward
and the rook does this job the best
from the side now for example if king g6
we're going to want to push our pawns
even further up the board
so f4 rook a3 check king h4
rook a2 and now what do you guys think
the best move
is here there's a couple different
really good moves
uh i'm just going to give you guys the
answer if you're watching the video at
home feel free to pause
try to figure it out but what you want
to do is bring this rook in
to b6 and this is the whole point of
having the rook
on the side is you can challenge these
squares in front of the pawns
using this rook now the enemy king is
going to be driven away like we've seen
in the past
and now we can push really either of the
pawns
but i like pushing this pawn first
because once again we want to give
ourselves shelter
from checks so after f5
let's say rook
a3 let's say let's say rook a1 for
example king g5
the point is we use these pawns to
protect our king
from checks the g pawn protects us from
behind
and the f pawn protects us from the side
no entry
for the rook if rook a4 for example
the idea is going to stay the same we
use our rook to push the enemy king away
and then we can start advancing our
pawns uh
if check up the board we
can let's say rook a8
to guard the back rank we can push
forward even further
and at the end of the day these pawns
are going to be quite simply unstoppable
push them forward and this is actually
checkmate without even having to promote
so i think this is a really useful end
game to know
now that's what it looks like when it
goes well what does it look like when it
goes
poorly so let's say we didn't use this
idea of
shielding our king with the pawns and we
didn't use this idea
of bringing the rook around to the side
right i wanted to show you guys the
proper technique first but now i want to
show you how can go wrong
and why it's better to do things that
the way i just showed
so let's say you start with the move f4
right it's a perfectly fine move to
start with
uh but now let's say that you know rook
c3 comes on the board and so you say
okay i want to push this pawn forward
i'm going to play
f5 well now all of a sudden after king
f6
it's not so clear how you are actually
advancing these pawns forward
you can try g3
let's say black just passes you come off
the board
now rook a4 is suddenly guarding your
king
if g4 now rook 8 will say
if king h4 our king doesn't have shelter
if king f4 our king doesn't have shelter
sorry let's say king g5 king f3 once
again
the king doesn't have shelter from the
side we allowed our opponent
king to get in front of the pawns and
because of that
this end game is actually going to be a
draw now so things can go
very very wrong very quickly for example
rick g1 is the only try to keep this
pawn defended if you try to go this
way now it's a little bit too late
because this guy is actually
going to fall well i guess in this case
we wouldn't want to take him
but in any other case this guy is just
falling off the board
in this case there's just no shelter
for the white king it starts going this
way look out
now with your king far away we are happy
to take this pawn
so things to avoid uh pushing the pawns
sort of willy-nilly
without your king to support them and
allowing the enemy king in front of the
pawns
that's sort of the idea that i wanted to
show you guys here so what's the proper
way to do it
proper way to do it is to give yourself
shelter from checks
and use your rook from the outside to
keep the enemy king
away from your pawns stuff like f4
and rook b6 keeping the king from
getting a nice
blockading square okay
you guys have a good grasp on that
now i wanted to ask you guys about
winning
this type of end game so how would you
go about
winning this type of position i feel
like this is one
that people in the chat room might not
be as familiar with
what do you people think in in the chat
room what do you people think
what's going on here
alex tell says keep to the dark squares
billy club
says trade the rook
ragnarok says rook on the side
ham says he's never had this ending fair
enough
so uh the point of this is not that i
think
this exact position is going to occur on
the board too
often but it's to show you how you can
kind of generalize
this idea sort of no matter what gets
thrown at you
uh be in a position like this or a
similar position you can almost always
relate it back to an end game you
already know
so in this case we know the king and
pawn versus king end game if we get our
king in front of the pawn with the
opposition
we are able to win so the way to
approach
this position is to think of it from
that perspective
if we can force our opponent to trade
off the rook for
the bishop for the rook and get a
winning king and pawn end game
then that's going to be very very good
for us so because of that
the idea is also the same from the two
pawns
uh position we just looked at where you
want the rook on the side
to control the squares in front of the
pawn
from afar taking advantage of the king
so now let's say king f6 king g3
bishop e6 white to move and win
in this position what's the easiest way
to win
right here
what do you guys think
so yes phoenix fire has the answer you
just play rook a6
and this is the easiest win of all time
the king
the bishop cannot move because it's
pinned to the king king moves out of the
way
we take the bishop next thing you know
we have a winning king in pawn end game
king f6
we take the opposition and we know how
to win
so because of this idea black now has to
play rather awkward moves like bishop c4
we bring our king up in front of the
pawn bishop d3 for example
now we want to use our rook to get rid
of the king unfortunately this bishop
is currently guarding this square so
just a move like rook c1 makes sense
this should be 5 to guard this square
but now rook b1
and after rook b6 the king has to move
out of the way
let's say king seven king e5 king f7
and we push the pawn up the board bishop
d3
we checked from the side as we already
know
from the rook end game we looked at king
e8
king e6 for example uh let's say bishop
c4 check
f6 bishop back to d3 we can check this
guy out of the way
and control our pawn
and now it's smooth sailing to promote
this pawn
and of course if black ever takes here
we should already know how to win
the rook and king against king and game
isn't rook b1 more accurate than rook a1
it doesn't really make a difference
manny
the point is you're just trying to get
the squares
uh to attack the king from this side uh
rook one might have gotten there a move
or two faster but
it didn't really matter in the end we as
long as we were getting to that sixth
rank
okay so the idea of course now
is you push the pawn forward and
eventually your opponent has to
sacrifice or else we will
make a queen and then we should already
know how to win
this position so hopefully you guys
learned a lot about these quote-unquote
essential end games
and more importantly this general idea
of when you learn the basic basic end
games
how you can relate them to almost any
end game position
uh if you're up material you'll know
when to trade
down when to go for these simpler end
games and you can use the ideas
from the simpler end games to help you
in the slightly more
complex positions i hope you guys
uh found this lecture useful i think
that is
going to just about do it here tonight
for this home edition of the end game
class
uh we are going to be continuing on
twitch with
analyze your games so if you're watching
live please head over to the twitch
channel
where you will see even more of me here
tonight if you're watching the youtube
video thank you so much for joining me
that's all for tonight